Called the four hour work week,
escape the nine to five live anywhere and
join the new rich and enjoys this line
this morning from New York. Good
morning. Good morning. Catchy title.
I gotta tell you this,
but can anyone really have a successful
career at a productive business on just
four hours a week? Are the
surprising answers? Yes.
If you'd asked me in
2002, I would've said no.
I put in the usual 8,200 hour,
quite literally workweeks
in Silicon Valley,
first as an employee and then as a CEO,
but a part of giving my guest lectures
at Princeton University and high tech
entrepreneurship led me to question a
lot of those assumptions about career and
work life balance. And after 20
countries and dozens of case studies,
the conclusion was yes, it can be done.
And it's really in a world where the
average work week is now 70 hours.
According to Forbes, the, the
option is either up or down.
And I think a lot of people want to go
down. A lot of people want to go down,
goes according to the Bureau
of Labor Statistics. Um,
more Americans are working longer
and longer than we ever have,
or we have just as obsessed with the job
that we are obsessed with getting ahead
or do we not understand how to work
more effectively and efficiently.
I think that there are
a number of issues. Um,
we have a certain dedication
in the u s to hyperactivity.
So it's a real fixation on,
on activity and being busy as
opposed to being productive.
And when you sit down and you look
at how, let's say Richard Branson,
the CEO version works,
uh, or you look at, uh,
the CEO of let's say Ikea,
you notice that there are some distinct
differences in how they operate.
They and we all have the same 24
hours. So when you break it down,
you see that even someone like Branson
says he can handle his business in the
first 15 minutes of each day if you
prioritize this properly. All right,
but for most, go ahead. And I want to
get to some of the examples because we,
when you talk about, uh, cutting
down a of the amount of time,
we don't have that much time.
So let's talk about this.
You say Americans can't eliminate 50%
of their work in the first 48 hours,
50% of their work in their, in just 48
hours. Tell us how that's possible too.
So the first thing you need to do is
define their work very clearly on,
and Peter Drucker said this was
the biggest challenge. So what,
how is my performance being
measured? Uh, once you do that,
you wanted to do an 80 20 analysis
and two ways. So the first,
as you look at the 20% of activities
that are really contributing 80% of the
desired outcomes. And then conversely,
you look at the 20% of people
and activities that are
consuming 80% of your time
and then work to minimize
or eliminate those.
And the effects can be quite dramatic,
especially when we cut out a lot of
the email distraction that people are
addicted to your socio. You're
saying focus, focus, focus.
In the book you mentioned trading your
boss to value a performance over presence
mean let's look at the final product as
opposed to the amount of time I spent at
the desk in the cubicle or in the
office. That's exactly exactly right,
so moving from a a presence based model,
where are you measuring ass
and seat time so to speak,
to a performance and results based model.
And so when I've spoken to companies
like Google and paypal and others,
they're already moving in that direction.
But even as an employee you can help
catalyze some of those changes on a
personal level and really train your
boss to look at your output as opposed to
just the hours that you're
putting in your eyes.
So don't worry about how much
time I spent at the office.
We'll look at the final
product in the book.
You also say we should go to the media
fast for one week and not be anything.
Turn off the TV, magazines,
newspapers, et Cetera,
except focusing on your book is that
seems a little dangerous to have people
live in a vacuum. But are you saying
this will help us to focus on our task?
It's a no, you're exactly right. It's
not so much operating in a vacuum,
but recognizing that in a digital world
you'll always have less attention than
information that's imposed on you. So, uh,
going on a low information diet and
blocking out the things that are either
irrelevant to your, your
objectives or in actionable,
which happens to be most things.
So really reestablishing those barriers
and filters is key to a single tasking,
so to speak. All right. And when
you, I guess we were saying once you,
once you accomplish this, but can
you join the new rich, I mean,
will you be able to find yourself getting
the pay raises and the increases that
you, that you, that you think
you've earned and deserve?
I absolutely envy the
keyword being earned. So, uh,
you'll find that as soon as you start
living a lifestyle and a career by design,
it's not only possible to increase
your output while decreasing the input,
but it's really mandatory because people
will abuse your time to the extent that
you let them.
And time is really what makes your income
valuable or not valuable. All right,
Tim Ferriss,
he's the author of the four hour work
week and escape the nine to five live
anywhere.
Enjoy the new rich and you can find
out more about him by logging onto our
website. More about the four hour work
week on our website, [inaudible] dot.
TV forward slash reporting.